i don't want your crappy system if your
system results
that i go into the store and i can only
buy pepsi cola or coca-cola or coca-cola
strychnine
something needs to change on a
fundamental level there's no reason to
be represented by someone you dislike or
despise or disagree with and it's not
reasonable for you to expect me to buy
into your chicanery
michael mallis welcome to the show thank
you sir
how are you dude i'm phenomenally doing
phenomenally well
yeah me too me too this has been a very
good week i think for both of us
oh okay we're talking about you now okay
i see how it is where are you in the
amazon charts now i know you've been
crushing it recently
i think i'm at 30 i'm only
39. how embarrassing i know so i have
all books
let's check right now let's look let's
have a little look here exactly let's
let's let's check it out like steve rule
says
so we're going here um
and we are at let's look at you on
amazon
it is thirty seven
ah the shame i know done with the pledge
the shame i feel i feel so embarrassed
yeah
well i love the idea of having an amazon
link which is essentially a one word or
a one url answer to a question that you
always get
asked about anarchy well i get asked a
lot and this is what
the whole point of the anarchist
handbook was so people could stop
bothering me
and read for themselves no you know what
what happened was when i first started
doing this sort of thing being a media
personality for lack of a better term
i my i i always had a strategy
and my strategy was um say something
interesting or say something
uninteresting in an interesting way
because there's no shortage of these
people who go on these shows you know
exactly what they're going to say it's
going to be republican talking points
democratic talking points
you know tory talking points labor
talking points
and let's just die on habit then you
definitely want to watch it because
that's the
best um and at a certain point
you know my platform increased and i
keep talking about anarchism people kept
asking me
and i'm like i don't want to explain all
this just do the homework leave me alone
and at a certain point like oh people do
care what i think and i'm like well
this is all the answers that they want
to know about historic there's a you
know it's a
collection of historical essays from all
the prominent anarchists in the past
well i don't want to say all but
the vast majority of them so why
do a collection of essays rather than
give your own interpretation of the
philosophy and the way that the politics
put together
um i think it's a good way to give
uh respect to those who have paved the
way
i think there's some people in there who
i've sort of
rescued from the dustbin of history
who've been forgotten
and to be able to sort of redeem people
who died you know who murdered
were killed for their views uh to be
able to bring that back
to also demonstrate you know showing
versus telling
i could tell people that the black flag
of anarchism comes in many colors
but it's another thing for them to read
and to see why these people may
agree on certain things but they are all
over the map in terms of
you know other things so i i think uh
and a lot of them will say better than i
will uh it's it's
i'm not going to outdo lysander spooner
when it comes to his essay on the
constitution so why even try so
uh and you know maybe at some point i
will be able to
uh do that book of my own but i think uh
it's it's premature and
and kind of superfluous why'd you choose
the name because there's the anarchists
cookbook which is a very different sort
of book
why did you choose the one that you went
for um i don't know i just felt like it
felt like an organic
so it wasn't some subversive reference
to something else
i didn't even think of the anarchist
cookbook when that happened it might
have been a subconscious thing
um yeah i i guess is all i don't have a
good answer
who would you put in that you couldn't
oh uh maybe chomsky i didn't think to
put him in
uh because he's less theory and more of
application
i we know chomsky probably the biggest
names maybe a few
like some christian anarchists or
lefties but it's already 365 pages and
like there's no question all the major
names are represented so
what's the best definition that you've
got for anarchy just elevate the pitch
you do not speak for me
that's interesting i think is it i've
heard you say anarchism is the belief
that citizenship is better when based on
ideology than
on geography yeah so that's the
application of the principle
the the concept of you know you and you
might be on
i don't even know what cell phone
companies they have over there you might
be on big
big ben i'm sure big ben network yeah
yeah you're on big ben and you're on
morning tea
breakfast sure i'm on high peers
uh when we're calling each other right
um
one company is i don't know how clear is
the market does my company pay you do
they split it is it the receiver is the
caller
uh to have it you know if it to have
things based on geography as opposed to
individual it's like your phone is
attached to where you live as opposed to
where you go
and if the ostensible purpose of the
basic purpose of government
which anarchist dispute is protection of
a person and their person and property
uh that would be the right wing
anarchist would believe in property
there's no reason for that to be based
on the physical
domicile as opposed to where that person
goes it's your father and
we have that in a very poor sense today
which is if someone's a tourist you know
they're still under the protection of
their home country
if someone is a diplomat they're are not
subject to the laws fully of the country
where they're staying at they're still
regarded as sovereigns
of where they used to be you see things
like julian assange you know even though
technically he's in
in britain he was still in the embassy
which is not considered british soil
because that's a legal arrangement so
you know those are examples
using governments about how this would
uh apply but it would just be
extrapolated fully as opposed to these
one-off cases
why do you refuse to vote well there's
an essay about that
that see this is exactly why i did the
book so when people are like why do you
refuse to vote i'll be like just buy the
book
uh but basically the premise is uh um uh
you know there's a few
slogans don't vote it only encourages
them but also i do not think that if you
if i would vote uh i would have a right
to complain
because if i'm hiring a lawyer and
that lawyer i'm saying speaks for me you
know this person represents me if i'm
hiring an accountant this person
you know i'm outsourcing i am
voluntarily granting them authority
if i go and say i want this person to be
my representative
and they do they change their word which
they will inevitably do
i brother i asked for it i said i want
this person to represent me and i do not
believe any politician
does or can represent me so it's
avoiding being complicit in the game
yeah and it also i i first of all it's
just a waste of time
so in terms of like ways to use your
time if you want to make the world a
better place
there's old people who are lonely
there's a dog you can foster there's
kids who don't have a dad who you can
mentor
there's so many different ways where if
you want to work for the common good and
make society a better place
if you just commit that one hour you
actually feed someone who's hungry buy
some work for an hour and buy a poor
person clothing there's just infinite
ways
that we could all marginally increase
the uh happiness you know
in the world around us so voting is a
ritual that validates
those who slaughter you know hundreds of
thousands of people in the name of
patriotism and things like this so it's
it's a
uh a you know not a fan of democracy to
put it mildly
how do you feel then in the build-up to
an election when obviously you get asked
a lot i've asked you on this show
ideas and insights around the election
is that
does that feel a little bit like playing
somebody else's game games it feel a bit
like oh god i just can't be bothered to
even discuss this arcade institution
not at all it's it's the opposite it's
that it's i'm being able to discuss it
without the facade that this is some
kind of noble endeavor
and you've got no agenda i do have an
agenda which is the destruction of the
state
um but it's also uh just exposing the
manipulations and machinations
of the parties the corporate media
social media and all these other
various uh figures so it's it's it
is of great interest and and you know to
watch
how this sociologically plays out even
though i don't regard any of it as
uh valid what's your favorite essay from
the new book
i john hasness who's a georgetown
university professor
uh he's alive he gave me permission to
do it i would say that one because he
talked about the myth of objective law
so you know the big sticking point for
most people to make the full transition
to anarchism is to have a legal system
and it you know the argument is okay
look at the very base we need to have
a system of law where everyone can come
together
and have a base agreement you can't do
this you can do that
and his being a law professor he
demonstrates that the idea of objective
law
is not only uh does not apply in reality
it's
literally impossible even in theory that
whenever you he gives many examples of
like look
whatever this legals case is and these
are you know not
uh these are just basic legal cases like
this person has a sweater this one
doesn't or something like that and
they nail it to each other you are going
to have
whoever is adjudicating this process
they are going to bring their world view
to the judgment inevitably
so there's no reason why everyone has to
be under the same
principle of law and i'll give you a
great example that's a very they'll be
very easy people to solve
you and i are both uh ebay uh we have an
ebay exchange and you're supposed to
mail it to me
and somehow it gets lost in transition
right so you can very easily imagine one
legal system where you're the seller
it's your responsibility to get to my
hands if you don't get into my hands
i get my money back another legal system
you could say well
i sent it my hands are clean take it up
at the post office right
both of those scenarios if they're
explicated ahead of time
which one is right which one is just
they both make perfect sense
and there's no reason why you can't
choose
which system of rules will govern your
behavior and
now it gets much trickier when you're
coming to things like violent crime
and murder and things like that and that
that's a kind of a separate issue that
we can get into later
but in terms of regarding that there has
to be one legal system with one set of
rules
that everyone has to follow is
demonstrably false second
the claim and any literally any lawyer
will tell you
if objective law were possible then you
would know
for a fact how that judge is going to
rule in your case right
if i buy something at the supermarket
and it's expired milk i'm getting a
refund you know ahead of time
but if this is a legal system you have
not only do you have no idea of the
outcome
you can be certain that the attorney's
fees are going to be exorbitant
and are going this is why how often are
people involved in lawsuits it's
regarded as a nightmare right
because the claim is that equality in
the law
even if you're very very poor you have
to have access to this system
of adjudicating disputes but everyone
knows
uh poor people do not have access to
lawyers and things like that they'll
have access to it if they're the
defendant
they'll have a public defender at least
in the states i'm sure probably the same
thing in britain
but in terms of a lawsuit they do not
have access to this
service which defenders of the of the
government will say
is crucially necessary to everybody how
would that be fixed in an anarchist
society
when you ha everything would be resolved
look at we have it
fixed right now in terms of ebay right
so right now
you and i have a dispute and ebay steps
in and either gives
me the refund or says i'm out of luck
chris sent the sweater
and it's even if i don't get the answer
i want
i at least don't have to buy a lawyer
and it's
resolved in seconds anarchism is not
utopia
there's still going to be theft there's
still going to be killing
they're still going to be missing
sweaters in the mail the
difference is the resolution of these
problems is going to be much more
efficient
cheaper and much more conducive to peace
as opposed to imposing
judgments that entire portions of the
population
find to be abhorrent that makes sense in
a very binary scenario that's easily
trackable
like an ebay situation but if it was a
more complex one stuff to do with
litigation in business law
business to business transactions
mergers money taxes
what about that surely that's just
equally complicated
sure so it would be the same thing as
going to a practitioner versus going to
a surgeon
right if you're going to have things
that are that technically complicated
you are going to have some kind of
higher level
uh court system to resolve it but again
even in that case it's still going to be
cheaper because there'll be competition
uh and different firms that we have that
right now again
private arbitration different private
arbitration would
uh have the capacity to compete in terms
of efficiency now the question becomes
well i don't what if i don't respect the
judgment of this private arbitration
uh that's when you have to you have
things like uh ostracism
uh things like um credit scores uh and
so on and so forth
uh having a bad credit score which are
done by it's not visa or mastercard or
you know american express or britain
express i'm guessing you have uh
which are the ones who are kind of uh
adjudicating the system you have credit
reports right
and they tell both the credit card
company and you what your credit score
is and they're saying
in my opinion these are the odds this
person is reliable in terms of repaying
their debts
and not only is there one there's three
of them so you would have the same sort
of situation where it's like okay
should you deal with you know williamson
co well historically
and it's only going to take one
williamson co agreed
to abide by the judgment of this third
party they refused and that's basically
going to
very factually say it's much riskier
to deal with this guy than it is to deal
with them where
even if they don't agree with the
judgment they still uh even they
personally don't agree they still follow
through with the results
it seems like there's a lot more work to
be done on the front end then with that
you might get through the litigation
side more quickly for
deploying the law but coming into it
it's going to be a little bit more
effortful at least in the beginning
because imagine how much all of this
would be to set up and you'd have to
have
some sort of agreed uh rules and
principles between the different
agencies that might be representing
someone so everyone would need to format
their
everything in the same way so there
still needs to be agreed rules and
procedures and regulations over the top
but as as we said earlier like with
let's go back to the cell phone example
i don't know and you don't know what
happens when i call you
and we have different cell phone
providers and we never need to know
because before those cell prone
providers came to market
they already established procedures on
how to deal with every other cell phone
company
so that their customers don't ever have
to worry about or think about it
so look at it this way in terms of
fashion the problem
if anything with fashion is we have too
many choices too many options we have
you know books and magazines telling you
which to choose but when it comes to the
law you don't have choice
um and it's much more expensive and
costly and the the reason
the law is such a concern as opposed to
fashion never being a political issue
is precisely because whatever the
government does it does poorly and
and that's uh to put it mildly
what do you think is the hardest
question
or the most difficult issue for an
anarchist society to
try and overcome uh what do you do about
the kids
because if you don't have a state and
kids are basically
under the dominion of their parents how
are you going to resolve
cases which there are no shortage of
when parents are bad actors toward your
their children that is a tough one and
that's a tough one under any scenario
that's the thing
one of the big issues in terms of people
attacking anarchism which is of course
their prerogative is they'll say well
anarchism is bad
because it's going to lead to war i'm
like wait the system you're advocating
doesn't lead to war so you can't have
this kind of double standard
so this is a criticism like okay you're
not going to have
um you know child protective services
possibly or maybe you would in a private
sense like you have a
apartment complex and you know i don't
know how they would resolve it
the point is it's horrible now like the
foster kid system
like many kids are you know subject to
abuse and it's certainly less than
uh ideal so i that's a good tough
question
and i do not have a good answer but i
don't think any system that's been
posited has had a good answer
and that's because typically there's
like
there's an agent within an anarchist
society that kind of opts in
to some of the services which then get
used but in a situation where
the only legal agent
is the bad actor themselves and you have
a dependent
that requires somebody to step in you
have this vacuum which is not being
filled by something
correct yeah that is a nasty situation
yeah and it's it's just it's just not i
it's just nasty in general
i don't know man i mean that's yeah
that's an ugly one what about what about
if
a country went to war with another
country i know this is in the second
half of one of the
one of the essays that i looked at yeah
uh well first of all wouldn't be another
country be like an anarchist area
um but we already see examples of this
in the past which is there's a
this is hilarious which is a criticism
of anarchism that like if you get help
from a state it's not anarchism at all
it's like well if someone
mails me food that doesn't make them the
government they're just someone who's
providing a service right
so as of right now like literally today
i as a private company can hire the us
government to provide security for me
this in no sense makes them my
government any more than hiring a
chauffeur
is the one who's my chauffeur they're
the ones taking orders not giving them
so there are many countries on earth
already this the argument is
well if the u.s went anarchists they'd
be invaded tomorrow by china
well why aren't we invading why isn't
the u.s invading canada by this logic
why isn't the vatican being invaded by
italy or monaco
uh by france there's many examples of
countries on earth right now
that do not have any
any military whatsoever and can easily
be overrun uh
so there's sure there are bigger
governments but no one is saying or
i'm certainly not saying that for
anarchism to be considered successful
has to be worldwide
there's no reason why you know if
ireland
was anarchist for thousands of years and
is used as an example historically of
how an anarchist system would work so uh
if you had an invasion
we saw what happened with kuwait let's
pretend kuwait instead of a government
have been an anarchist area you saw a
lot of self-interested
nations with big armies step in
and also it's much harder to invade and
conquer an area where everyone
is armed and trained in using their
weaponry
[Laughter]
i mean look at afghanistan look at
vietnam i mean this this argument people
say that like well
there's an anarchist area like you know
they'd be conquered immediately
china's not having a fun time conquering
hong kong so the claim
that this is something that's just done
like with a snap of
snapping of fingers is nonsensical it's
very very hard to invade and conquer
and very at the very least very
expensive can you see there being an
anarchist state in your lifetime well no
because by definition there wouldn't be
anarchical state but uh
anarchism is a relationship how should i
keep on getting that wrong how should i
refer to it
sure just an anarch you could call it
anarchist area or society but anarchism
isn't a location it's a relationship
right so you and i have an anarchist
relationship neither of us has an
authority over the other
if there was a dispute we would not be
calling the state which state would we
call
i mean the possibility of this kind of
international lawsuits
nonsensical and even if you were here or
i were there and
we got drunk and someone got violent
we're still not calling the cops
so you know it's and every country is in
an anarchist relationship with one
another
the example i use in the book is if a
canadian kills an american in mexico
there's no one to call that's above them
right the three nations have to have
some system in place ahead of time to
adjudicate this process
and as we said earlier we can be certain
that they have adjudicated this ahead of
time uh in that
it's not like when that happens they're
like what do we do let's call congress
the process is already in place ahead of
time so whenever someone is in the
process of providing services
they're going to anticipate as much
these things as possible so that their
consumers are
satisfied with it and we see this in a
done in a very haphazard
and hand-fisted way with uh uh
governments right now
okay and you can't see in your lifetime
there being an area that turns
oh i can't oh yeah yeah oh it's it's
it's not going to be that hard either it
just has to be
even just like there's many or
organizations right now that are trying
to basically
uh make things like hap this happen like
seasteading or or other such
uh situations i i think if people read
between the lines
there has been in recent years yeah or
as you would say yes
a lot of hand-wringing over
the increasing um diligent
lack of legitimacy of the state and
increasing
um distance between populations and
their governments and they're not
feeling represented
and that's something that's healthy and
from my perspective should be encouraged
as much as possible
although of course members of the
corporate media think this is a
nightmare in disaster
because they go hand in hand with state
power where do you think would be the
most likely anarchist area to rise up
first
oh i have no idea uh in the same way
that marx had said there's no way that
russia's ever gonna go communist and
that's where it had ended up happening
russia ended up that's where it ended up
happening so
it could be just someone creates a new
physical space
um or someone creates some kind of micro
city somewhere i mean
this is the beauty of markets you don't
know you can't predict where how they
will operate where they'll pop
up what was unique about the process for
creating this book i know that you were
really proud and interested in that
uh what was unique about it i think um
knowing that this i something i took
very seriously what was unique is
knowing that this is something that's
not going to be dated for
many many years and that uh it's going
to be
the go-to reference book for a lot of
people about an idea which in their
internet circles at least
is gaining increasing uh currency so
that was
uh kind of something special talk me
through the writing process and the
publishing process you said that there
was
some lessons to be taken from that sure
so there was a you know again i i've
been getting
asked about this constantly because i
you know i talk about this stuff on all
these different
big podcasts and the only thing that had
been somewhat comparable to what i was
looking for was this book called
patterns
of anarchy from like the 60s and one of
my supporters this woman named marla
i was doing a live stream and she went
in the super chat and she goes why don't
you do an audio book of this
and i go that's a good idea like wait a
minute these are public domain i should
just redo it
in a contemporary way update it with you
know bigger names and more controversial
essays and you know and i also
you know being a collector of many
things i
knowing how to curate a collection i
knew okay these are all the names i have
to have covered
and also which are the concepts i want
to have covered so to kind of have that
grid
uh it was was the process and you
managed to get it from
idea to market in three and a half
months
yeah it was three and a half months and
now i'm recording the audiobook
what's the lessons from that i have to
start recording the audiobook
the lesson is my i don't have good
enough sound quality in this room yet so
i have to figure out how to do it
yeah i bet you don't but you went
self-published as well
correct and we i was the top
non-fiction book on all of amazon for
over a day
uh beating literally everyone uh there's
a novel ahead of me and dr
seuss and i was number three so this
this guy
obama you might have heard of oprah
winfrey you might hurt her
every president every pm i was
gordon gordon brown get out of my way
you got nothing on me jeffrey howe sorry
i was just running the table and still
am and it's um
very validating to show people
that you can do it yourself and do and
this is another example like we're just
talking earlier about in terms of
adjudicating disputes
if i'd gone through a mainstream
publisher let's assume the sales would
have been the same
at the very least it's coming out in
2023. yeah so even if the results were
identical
i'm still saving two years of my life in
it or my career
that is an enormous enormous difference
well dude i was
uh saw a tweet from thiago forte who's a
productivity coach guru who's got a deal
for his first book which will be really
really awesome and everyone's excited
about it coming out in the productivity
community
and he hit the nail in the head and said
the weird thing about
a book is that you need to be able to
project the trend
two years out and then catch it just as
it's hitting the inflection point
and he was really fortunate because he
talks about building a second brain it's
a personal knowledge management system
where you can have all your notes and
your summaries and such like organizing
a very good way on your computer
and notion and rome have all had these
huge
influxes of investment and there's lots
of interest and it's been
lots of press and publishing around and
he's like this is great because i think
he's maybe one year into the process
so he's looking at the start february
2022 i think is when he's looking at
doing it
he's thinking right yeah i have managed
to time it but all of this investment
and all of this clout that's just
occurred within the industry that he's
written a book in
is totally out of his control because
the lag time
between him coming up with the idea and
even
between him finishing the book and then
the book finally hitting market
it was so vast there's a couple other
things
no editor who hires me is going to know
this field as much as i do
so there's going to be arguments just
based on their limited knowledge in
terms of why do you have this sense they
would have that one i don't need to
explain myself
because i know what i'm doing in this
very specific regard
number two and this is something people
might not appreciate i did a book
a few years ago called concierge
confidential i was the co-author
and there's a typo page the end of page
chapter one says i'm about to t-o-o
i told we told the publisher they didn't
fix it for the paperback they don't care
with uh the amazon program which i use
to self-publish
there was a typo in the book you fix it
you re-upload it
and since it's print on demand instantly
it's fixed
so to have that kind of dynamic
publishing system is also
of enormous benefit and a huge advantage
it shows now
just it kind of explains why people are
so concerned with status and clout
in 2021 because with the right audience
that's sufficiently bought in and broad
enough
you can do some pretty powerful things
even up against the powers that be
all of the previous pathways and avenues
and contacts that they've got
one guy with a 100k on
youtube and a couple of 100k on
twitter can do some damage yeah
that's the thing it's uh people want
to when you see someone making it happen
on their own
you want to be a part of that you know
this isn't someone who's got some big
book deal with simon schuster
and they're rolling out and like oh yeah
this book sounds good i want to buy it
but if you see someone who's like this
book is something i would buy anyway
but it's also someone i'm a fan of doing
it themselves
and beating the corporations at their
own game
then you really want to cheer them on
and feel and and there's also that kind
of feeling of like
this is my opportunity to actually make
a difference and and
invest what 20 19 and 1 cent
uh you know to kind of say this is what
i want to see more of
so you know i'm a big fan of albert
camus
uh he denied he did not like being
called an existentialist he regard
himself as an absurdist
but the existentialist idea that we are
self-created
uh when you see someone who is you know
you have
the guy who is killing it on amazon
and running circles around all the
publishers is awesome
and i had the opportunity to be him so i
mean that kind of mindset
you know i give talks in networking
sometimes and i tell the kids i'm like
if you know someone
is in town and they're having their
birthday and they're not doing anything
take them out
and do it i do it for i say i do it for
selfish reasons and they laugh and i go
no no
that guy is awesome but that could be
you the only thing stopping you is 30
and an hour of your time and people
don't think in those terms
i think this is one of the seductive
qualities of a glass door policy when
doing any sort of creative process so
people have known that this was coming
you know it happened at least in terms
of the origin on a live stream that
other people would have seen
so they've seen it right from seedling
to fully grown plant
and for such a long time the creative
processes had this sort of mystique and
this magic behind it
and now being able to watch that unfold
it's like when you go into a car factory
and you go
okay so that those four points are going
to turn into wheels and then a chassis
and then all of the engines going to be
put in
and you can watch it and then it becomes
a car and there's something fascinating
people say is it that you don't want to
know how tv or sausages are made the
sausage yeah
yeah but watching a book be produced
and even seeing the seeing the artist go
through
all the vicissitudes of the difficulties
had a really bad day writing had a
really good day writing
founding it hard finding it easy i think
this
yeah people like that because they buy
into stories and narratives right and
not just the ones that you publish
the meta narratives that are about what
was the process of publishing this like
if if as an anarchist you're saying
we can win and we can beat these huge
establishment entities who have been
entrenched for centuries
um that's a big that's a big ask that's
a big bold claim
so to have that concept be demonstrated
in any capacity
and to have it be demonstrated and
unambiguously
is i think of enormous motivation to
many people
even if they're not anarchists at all
but are simply people who want
independent creators who are you know
sticking their neck out to succeed
that's there's a guy called jack butcher
who's uh on the she's been on the show
recently and he's a british guy
in the states who's one of the most
innovative creators i think in the world
at the moment he's doing incredibly well
and one of the main reasons is that he
is so glassed or with
everything that he does when he's
considering a new project he'll post
about it on twitter
if he's had a really good day with the
shop he'll upload his shopify stats
he'll
show the back end of what he's working
on who he's spoken to potential projects
that are happening
and people just love that they love
being involved in the narrative and it
makes sense because why are people
bothered about
sitcoms your [ __ ] friends coming back
after 25 years off or whatever
people are bothered about that because
they're bought into the story arc of
what's going on with this person
and i think we're only really only just
scratching the surface about what the
creator economy can do
with opening oh yes the creator's own
personality
aside from the work so the art and the
artist are now being sold
as two separate entities that come
together to form like one plus one
equals four
with this and they create even more and
here's the other thing it's like if now
i can tell people with a straight face
for 500 right you can send me
to miami to do andrew shelter's show
or if you're interested in spreading
these ideas that pays for half of an
office
of some rando at a think tank to write
white papers
that no one's going to read which of
these is going to see a better return on
investment for you
and again this is it's an easy sell to
make because this is unambiguous
so again i'm one of the reasons i am an
anarchist
is i am such a fan of all the people in
the book
who really were marginalized
complete pariahs fought for their vision
sometimes were killed for their vision
um and
to whatever ex i just think that such a
um
like guy thing to do to forge to to make
your own path where none had existed
before
and show other people the way and that
it's possible i mean
that to me is just something very um
primal
about that there's something that i
really enjoy as well
grabbing yourself by those bootstraps
and getting going as well it makes me
think of i know you're a fan of crypto
and
bitcoin and stuff sure it makes me think
about the proof of work concept
so being able to watch a creator go
through this process
all of the different areas and stages
and then even reflect on it once it's
happened and then thinking about what
comes next
that is proof of work right you're not
going to get scammed there was no way
that you were going to do this
and this book actually be 360 pages of
blank
sheets and you are actually my entire
career leading up to this point was just
a big
ponzi scheme sort of chill thing so that
i could then
pull a couple of grand out of everybody
and and
run away that was never going to happen
because people have this proof of work
look at all of the time that i've
invested
and um yeah man long may it continue
yeah i
am really really uh stoked and i'm also
really stoked at the reactions because
people
are feeling uh i think correctly
that their faith in me has been well
placed and that's something i take quite
seriously
you talk about bitcoin like this is like
getting in on duck
crypto this is like getting in a bitcoin
when it's 50 bucks yeah
yeah yeah yeah i like that as well with
creators
because i've been using this for a while
saying like look if you subscribe now
then you can say that you listen to
modern wisdom before it was cool
yeah and being that first one in because
you never know how big it's going to get
you never know how high that hockey
stick and inflection is going to go
and i think it's safe to assume that you
can just hold
your market share now and the amount
that the creator economy
is going to increase all of the
different ways stuff that dave rubin's
doing the way that people can now accept
different payments
the stuff that's happening on blockchain
so that you can have guaranteed
uh products that come to you all of the
clever stuff that's happening there
it's only further and further enabling
individual creators look at the money
that people on twitch are making
even just small guys in their bedrooms
you know they were doing this anyway
they were playing these games anyway
they've hooked up they've hooked up a
camera we would have had this chat in
any case
you know we just hook up a camera and
then you go away and yeah it's crazy
i don't even think though it's about the
money per se i think it's just about
like
you can just have a roof over your head
like a very basic maslow's hierarchy of
needs this is something people i think
don't often appreciate
because they think well you know if they
want to be a stand-up comedian for
example it's like who do you think you
are
jerry seinfeld it's like you don't have
to be jerry seinfeld to be a working
comic
there's literally thousands of comedians
you and i haven't heard of
who are still making a living maybe even
making a great living
at practicing their craft so the more
demonstrations of this that there are
that you don't have to hit you know be
the top seller in amazon like myself
but you could certainly do a decent job
and
uh be proud of yourself and that when
you go to meet your maker
you could point to your bookshelf and be
like hey i wrote that crappy book
that sold 500 copies that's that's the
big deal
that's more than 99 of people can say
i was reading through the book and one
of the questions that i had for you was
what's wrong with how democracies are
run and you there's this quote that says
people will say with a straight face
that having one choice for dear leader
is tyranny but having two is freedom is
that second choice
on the ballot really the qualitative
difference that's so good
but it's true if you go to this i don't
know what brands you guys have over
there but if you go to store in your
choice of coke and pepsi and someone
could say with a straight face hey
you can choose whatever you want it's
it's it's um or
or if you the choices are let's put
another if you're a partisan the choices
are coke or
literal or strychnine it's also you know
what i mean
but if there's if your system is set up
by design both in america we have
primaries right so there's a whole year
where all these people who want to be
the candidate for republican or democrat
are whittled away
so you're left with two candidates so
the whole process by design
is to eliminate your personal choices
and they're saying well
we don't have any other options well the
option is well i don't want your crappy
system
if your system results that i go into
the store
and i can only buy pepsi cola or
coca-cola or coca-cola strict nine
something needs to change on a
fundamental level
there's no reason to be represented by
someone you dislike or despise or
disagree with
and it's not reasonable for you to
expect me
to buy into your chicanery it is bizarre
that you hear people talk about
what this was the worst of the best of a
bad bunch right
we're talking about the people that
determined the standard of our lives the
lesser of two evils
in no other context are you forced
to do this can you imagine like you
you're
like you you're you're arrested and it's
like we got two barristers for you i'm
trying to use the lingo
it's like this one you know it doesn't
speak english
and and this one you know is in a coma
like
what what is going on here have you
learned any lessons that you've
really cherished recently
uh yes this was a very very intense one
i learned
uh some of the people in this book had
been largely forgotten
uh and that i got to
that i have the power to be the one to
redeem them in a sense and bring them to
a mass audience
and you know 100 years after they died
that was a big lesson and it really did
a number on me
i imagine that's beautiful to think yeah
but it's extremely intense
like who the hell am i you know i'm not
a modest person but in this context it's
like
you know these people are hanged uh you
know louis ling was the cover model
he wasn't he was sentenced to death he
blew off his own jaw
in prison wrote on the wall hurray for
anarchy in german
um you know he was like 23 24
just total hunk and you know he's
people forgot about him and this is
someone who valued
this world view enormously and his
courtroom speech
where he tells the judge the judge who
just sends him to death
like you're gonna cut he's like i told
the cops you come at us with guns we're
gonna come at you with dynamite
and he's like i'm four force and and i'm
i despise this court hang me
so like to have his voice uh and they
you know permeate through the decades
and i'm the one who made this happen is
is a um
very intense now obviously i'm not a
advocate of
you know dynamite to put it mildly but
it's still this is someone who
was a very interesting figure it's
something that i've been thinking about
i heard rogan say
on a show a couple of years ago one of
the best things about having a podcast
is
being able to find people who are
brilliant but don't have a platform and
giving them that
and joe said that about lex when i was
on yeah he's like i love that i can take
this
amazing treasure lex friedman and like
give him a bigger audience and now he's
killing it
yeah it's and you see that now it's
interesting watching the ark
because when you begin a show as a
creator especially like this you're
asking people favors
the power dynamic is that
they are doing something for you as a
fledgling podcaster or youtuber or
whatever um but then after a little
while
that power dynamic actually starts to
shift yeah you actually start to think
well
hang on a second you are the prize which
i love to use
as an example from pickup artistry i
keep on thinking well
hang on a second that jordan peterson
gets to come on here
no one else's clip of him did 1.6
million views
no one else's clip of him did one point
one million views the week later no no
blah blah blah
blah blah you think well actually after
a little while you get to do that and
then you go okay and not only
can i stand toe to toe with these people
that i really admire and look up to
which is a beautiful thing to be able to
do
but i can also find these diamonds in
the roof out of nowhere
found this guy called adam lane smith on
twitter wrote a really good
fascinating tweet thread about human
psychology being
just just some bloke that had been a
counselor and a therapist for
two decades and i was like this is
[ __ ] awesome this thread is [ __ ]
if this guy can podcast half as well as
he can tweet yeah
this is gonna be and sure enough brought
him on and he crushed it
second highest played podcast this guy's
a nobody in terms of clout
second highest played podcast of this
year behind jordan peterson on
audio ahead of monsters absolutely
including yourself
and um i was just like he messaged me
the other day
and was like dude everything's changed
michaela's brought him on her show he's
now gone on hers because she listened to
it and she loved it
and uh he was like dude i've got i've
got clients coming out with my ears i've
got all
offers to come on a podcast and you know
this isn't some sort of
simply whimpering guy this is a very
capable human being that just
required a little bit more pullback on
the elastic band
of the slingshot and it's [ __ ]
awesome so i totally get what you mean
platforming people
being able to give voices to those that
deserve one uh
is yeah it's sick it's endlessly
rewarding
and it's also even more intense when
these are people who gave their lives
um so like um albert parsons was one of
these
people he was there was a bomb in
haymarket in chicago in the late 1800s
he
had left the rally they um him
and his comrades were um there was a
warrant out for them
he was on the lam he said i'm going to
stand in solidarity nothing's going to
happen
they're all sentenced to death uh you
know we have the letter from these
people to their children
uh his wife wasn't allowed to see him
hanged and when he went to the gallows
he's like can i say a few words and then
mid-sentence they killed him
um so and she had his picture on his
wall
uh until she died in 1942 there's a
picture of her pointing to it
so you know to to be able to i'm gonna
get into him you know on some livestream
or something like that
but be able to tell his story uh you
know
he was he some of the men were told if
you ask for
um uh um forgiveness
uh the governor will commute your
sentence and some of them did
and parsons said no because that's
admitting guilt i didn't kill anyone
i spoke at a rally and i left like
you're
sentenced me to murder for my views and
they they
did it they killed him he was later
posthumously pardoned there's a monument
to him
um and the others in chicago right now
in a cemetery but yeah it's it's
to have people point out to be the one
to point out
uh these they're not giants in terms of
clout as you would say but they're
certainly
giants in terms of in narrative and in
terms of inspiration
and in terms of a story that that's so
it's it's very humbling and i hate that
word
because it has it's all often sounds
phony but it's it's let's put it
let me use different language it's very
jarring
and like awe inspiring that i'm in this
position
uh to be able to kind of make sure he
hasn't been forgotten
what's interesting is that someone's
quality of work
and their ability to deploy that and get
it seen by the masses don't always
necessarily align
you know we all know the people that
have huge
platforms and really don't do anything
with them but
similarly there are people who would
have deserved a platform he would have
been absolutely phenomenal but
for some reason wrong timing wrong place
wrong whatever
didn't do that and yeah it's it's odd
being able to think well
hang on this person might be even more
capable than me even at something which
i profess to be capable
at sure and yet i'm somehow the enabler
of their access to market or to an
audience
it is i can understand why it's jarring
yeah it's a good way to put it yeah
yeah there's this concept called
arbitrage in business where basically i
think
if i use this correctly please don't
yell at me but basically if i see a
stock that's at forty dollars and i know
that the market value is sixty dollars i
buy it quickly and then i
flip it because and i kind of align it
with with the market
and that's i think kind of what i'm
doing here is this person is
right now in terms of historical values
low because he's not known
and be like well hold on a minute this
is someone who did matter and someone
who was important so to be able to
kind of take them out of that dustbin as
i said earlier and
and you know to put them back on a
pedestal i i think is just
just absolutely a wonderful position to
be in
dude i got this lesson i got to tell you
right so last couple of months maybe two
months or so
i noticed that my thoughts were getting
really slow
and yeah it was it was odd man because
usually it feels like
skating on ice and it was like walking
through a swamp it was so
not like me and i was walking into rooms
and forgetting while i was there and i
was doing podcasts and stuff and
losing words you know i i pride myself
on precise speech and precise thoughts
and
i was forgetting words i forgot this
place called blackpool near manchester
seaside town in the uk
and i spent five minutes internally
trying to desperately remember this
place on the west coast
and then eventually got blackpool and i
was like what the actual [ __ ] is going
on here like
is this early onset dementia or am i
going see now i made some jokes with
somebody i was like oh like the aneurysm
is coming on blah blah blah
but after the blackpool incident i was
like right there's something
severely up here this this is beyond me
just being tired and i was constantly
tired i was going to bed at
nine o'clock at night really fatigued i
wasn't performing in the gym i was
constantly drowsy
so anyway messaged my buddy uh hold on
because this happened to me also last
year and i
figured it was a i developed a dairy
sensitivity
okay this it's not dairy sensitivity it
might be
it might have been enabled by that for
people listening if this is happening to
you try expert because i eat the same
thing every day
because of my regimen try experimenting
with your food which is so in this
hippie stuff but
it in my case this was the case i'm
sorry elimination diets work like that
specifically for that reason fodmap diet
if someone wants to look at the most
uh common foods that cause inflammation
and stuff like that use fodmap and you
take everything out and you add the main
one back one by one it's really easy way
to do
what you're advising there but it's
wholesale approach rather than oh
let's just get rid of dairy so anyway
i'm doing this i messaged my body i'm
like look
what's going on he said dude so tell me
about what supplements you've been
taking any changes that you've made any
medication and i thought
actually sort of about two months ago
this very boring medication that i was
on since the start of the year super
like normal pill
uh the doctor had said to to double the
dose he told me to double the dose about
two months ago sent it to him and he was
like dude that's
a uh an anticholinergic
drug and choline is one of the key
neurotransmitters
oh my god so what is crap what it does
is it down regulates that and sure
enough you do a little bit of digging
you go through
common side effects for moderate high
doses which is what i would have gone to
once i went to
double dose drowsiness fatigue uh memory
loss
um dry mouth which i didn't i didn't
have
uh and i was like dude like tick tick
tick tick this is all
me right i was like well great like
not an aneurysm but i had managed to
knock 30 points off my iq and basically
[ __ ] myself
to this state where i couldn't remember
blackpool and i'm like
it what's going on like so anyway easy
solution
right easy solution not an aneurysm just
get rid stop stop taking this particular
medication
but what it taught me that it really was
quite
profound was the inevitable
end point that we're all going to get to
with our cognitive decline and it was
really scary man
because you and me and
most of the people that are listening
probably will we rely
on our cognitive horsepower raw
sheer force to just pull us out of
problems we know that it doesn't really
matter whatever kind of a problem we get
ourselves into
because we have faith that the decision
engine between our ears is going to be
able to
fix it but there's something so
vicious and cruel about the thing that
you rely on
to fix the problems being taken away
from you and i
i have a friend whose dad was going
through um some
sort of cognitive decline and he said
this disease has taken everything from
me
you know it's even taken myself and i
was like wow
like that that quote didn't make sense
and after this last period i'm aware
like i forgot the word blackpool and i
was
you know misspelling right with right
and going into rooms and not knowing why
i was there
and thankfully it's reversible but man
like if people go back they can listen
to podcasts and
they might not notice but if they listen
carefully they can i'm forgetting words
i can't find the word that i mean which
is totally not like me
so for a brief period i kind of had it
was a decline it wasn't to this
you know something chronic it wasn't
something as severe as it could have
been but
it was really yeah it's really sort of
made me see a lot of things in a
different light it's
it was really like insightful but
terrifying the same same breath
and look what it's done to your speech
half these words you're not pronouncing
correctly
um this happened this happened shoot up
what the school
uh this happened to my mentor harvey
picard before he passed he was telling
me how he was
dealing with memory issues and he got so
scared he'd like sit there and start
trying to remember old phone numbers and
people's addresses just to kind of test
himself yeah
but i don't think that helps i think
that just is like you can't
it's not like like if you're out of
shape you go to the treadmill and you're
going to get some good cardio in
i don't think that these little sprints
so to speak in your mind
are going to do anything other than make
you afraid or make you be like okay
next time this happens it's going to
take like you said five minutes
but it's it's very very very very scary
with the same reason i think why you do
that
is why it's really difficult to not
think of a terrible action once you've
put it in your mind
so imagine that you're looking at a kid
by the side of the road
and you might have the thought i wonder
what it would be like if i pushed that
kid in out into traffic you go that's
terrible
that's a terrible thought you're just
telling yourself which is kind of dumb
because like who the [ __ ] are you
talking to right you're just telling
yourself and
also listening and also disgusted with
you and you think
i'm going to push that kid no i'm
obviously not going to push the kid out
into the middle of the road but
what a terrible thing to think i mustn't
think about it and then you immediately
start to think about it even more or you
know you're
with someone at work or whatever that
you really know that you shouldn't be
looking at or thinking about doing
something to and then you're like i
i can't stop thinking about it the
reason is that the mind's teleological
right so we posit a goal
what i think the reason is there's a
certain percentage of this audience
that is higher than one percent and less
than 50 that looks at you and thinks
this guy must be a sociopath
and a new not a maybe not american
psycho but british psycho
okay and not to have you be like oh yeah
i wonder what it's like to push this kid
in front of traffic
yeah okay yeah
yeah um but the reason is right the
direction
he's doubting me i'm not excited to
[ __ ] explain something
without you just coming in with your
american russian accent
anyway so um the brain's teleological
you set yourself a goal and then what
you do is your brain is constantly
measuring how far you are from that goal
okay but the problem is the very thing
that you are trying not to do is what it
set the goal as oh my god i can't
believe that's a thing i mustn't think
about it
how far away from the thing am i and in
the act of working out how far away from
the terrible thought about the kid in
the road or whatever
you continue to bring it back up and i
think it's kind of the same with the
memory loss situation
that you think okay this is something
that i'm concerned about and i really
don't want to have happen so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to see how far
away
how long is it for me to remember this
person's phone number from 20 years ago
or whatever it might be
oh my god well it's this long oh my god
well it's this long and then you end up
with this metacognizant
two layers three layers removed and
that's when it becomes really vicious
right because you
start to be the architect of your own
discomfort
you are the voice inside of your head
that is telling you the things about the
thing that is happening
and that that being your own torturer in
that way is uh
yeah again particularly cruel with now
increasingly or decreasingly
less ability to deal with the problem
because it's inherently
reducing your capacity yeah many years
ago i read a book called don't talk
don't think about monkeys it's about
people with tourette's and they're
writing essays trying to explain what
it's like
and i thought so people think tourette's
means you're always yelling out curses
and inappropriate things that's
coprolalia
and that's actually a fairly small
percentage of people tourettes but they
do have things like ticks they do blurt
things out and
and so on and so forth and they're like
try to imagine you know you
meet a genie and the genie says i'll
give you any three wishes you want on
one condition you don't think about
monkeys and at that point it's just like
oh crap
so that's kind of what it's like for
them and it's it's not fun
yeah what do you think about the bill
and melinda gates
breakup i have not been following this
at all
uh um i don't find him to be an
interesting figure
um i i think he's a nefarious figure but
i don't have enough kind of data to back
that up
um yeah it's just it's one of those
things that there seemed to be when
bezos had his breakup it kind of made
sense
because you look at jeff and you've got
this sort of nerd-to-chad
sort of autist to alpha um
trajectory that he's been on you think
well yeah obviously like obviously he's
the sort of guy walking around looking
like terminator with his
abs yeah leather jacket and stuff you
think well yeah obviously this is going
to happen
but bill and melinda you know you've got
this bill and melinda gates foundation
and so on and so forth
yeah it just seemed it seemed like an
interesting cultural artifact obviously
it's kind of
highly tied to this jeffrey epstein
thing and then it would appear that some
of the people that were
accused co-conspirators for the jeffrey
epstein case have you seen that they are
now
testifying against jillaine maxwell you
see that oh yeah i did see that yeah
yeah
yeah so but i don't understand how that
works either because do you
can someone implicate themselves during
their testimony
about somebody else have they been given
deals so that if they testify against
her they're not going to
they're going to be safe from no matter
what so that they can completely open up
about the situation i think it's going
to be hard to avoid perjury
and that's the other thing about
anarchism is we're told about equality
under the law but that's completely a
lie and this is a great example which is
uh people who plead up right
i will you're you are a drug dealer and
i want to
you know get your boss and as the
prosecutor i say
i'm i'm choosing not to punish you for
your crimes
in exchange for your testimony so in
other words i am as the government as a
monopoly and providing security
choosing not to enforce this so-called
objective law
for the sake of someone who i think is
better that's a value judgment
so as opposed to can you imagine a store
or a bodyguard saying well i'm not going
to protect you this person forever
dubious reason
so that's a good example of how the
state and its claims
of being fair reasonable and objective
on a daily basis throws that out the
window
and says this person is more important
than this one now there might be
something to be said for that
but it certainly is not the case that is
equality under the law that's a really
good point because it's a
you could say this person is further up
the food chain because what because they
make more money because
they tend to be in charge but it is at
the end of the day a subjective
viewpoint
why would that person be more of a
criminal than this person
or if they're both criminals how are you
the one who's like yes no no no yes
in terms of who you're going to
prosecute um
what about the covid's turnaround from
facebook now
that covered skepticism in terms of the
origin of it have you had a look at this
yeah oh yeah they're dropping their uh
um
i i this is i think going to be very
revelatory to very many people hopefully
uh and i my i pray uh every day to loki
that this is going to make some people
realize
how duplicitous uh the overlords are
why well because you know to come in
with
global pandemic you're coming in you're
asking we're gonna shut down the earth
uh you were gonna shut down any
discussion about certain aspects of this
like you should
if you question it we're just going to
lose your social media account which is
something that is something
very necessary for very many people
obviously and now to be like
oh yeah maybe we were wrong it's just
like that's an enormous amount of power
for people to have and to assume that
this power is being used reasonably
or uh objectively has been demonstrated
to be false
just to show that they don't have
capacity these people aren't
the clairvoyant all-seeing eye that they
really need to be the only way that you
would be able to deploy this sort of a
rule is if you were omnipotent and you
knew
i know all of the facts and i can make
the most educated
decision but when essentially what you
had
was people who knew more than the
politifact and the fact checking
organizations and facebook and twitter
and such like
and they were penalized as much as i
hate brian rose and i think the guy's a
pleb
uh he has someone like david icon and he
talks about i mean
i think it was 5g lizard people or
whatever for him but
still the skepticism about the origin of
kovid was
true much as it pains me to say that
um but people were penalized for holding
what now is actually considered to be
a plausible if not a realistic
view and let's also talk about nuance
let's suppose okay
it's completely ridiculously and absurd
and nonsensical
that covet was made in a lab in china
that is might be factually true but what
is truthful
is that governments and i'm not saying
this would happen or not because i'm
just saying
entities are currently trying to
bioengineer viruses
like that is a broader point that needs
to be addressed rather than the
specificity of this case
so you're doing this baby bathwater
situation where you're saying okay
you can't discuss this even as a
hypothesis but at base
there is a 100 certainty that things of
this nature
are being carried on all over the
country by various governments and you
could easily make the cases something
that's a good thing
if you bioengineer one you can reverse
engineer it maybe cure diseases
it doesn't have to be nefarious but what
is nefarious
is to kind of arbitrarily as mark
zuckerberg
or as dr fauci uh who's one individual
draw the line
and say not only can you not discuss
this
if you do discuss this this is going to
have great personal consequences for you
when it's something where it's it's not
even a person has a vested interest in
it's not like
i'm committing slander i'm going online
and saying chris williams this this and
that
and you could see them coming and be
like all right we're not going to have
our platform being used
to spread literal lies that chris did so
on and so forth
these are if there's anyone who should
not be given the benefit of the doubt
it's governments in general and if
there's any one government
that should not be given the benefit of
the doubt it's the chinese government
um yeah and there's no recourse either
right you know you
you lose your account or you're locked
out of whatever for x number of
months or weeks the recourse is
having these uh entities be regarded
with increasing skepticism and disdain
and creating alternative pathways to
information flowing which i think
there's an enormous movement online
from people who are much smarter than
both of us put together to create these
work around so this sort of thing can
happen in future dude every
couple of videos has a comment from
someone citing a new platform
yeah that i don't know about that i need
to upload my videos to
that i've got a list of them i've kept
it i've kept a list somewhere it's like
five or six other video hosting platform
well this one this one's decentralized
this one's on the blockchain
library's the one i think that everyone
likes their audiences
look you know there you go there's three
there's three different platforms that
we're talking about
but man i remember the first
conversation that mean you had about
anarchism and
what you were talking about was the fact
that how many times do you need to be
hit over the head with a stick
or mistreated by powers that be so that
they show you that they do not have your
best interests at heart
before you start to see that there might
be something you miss here
and i don't know whether this is a quirk
of my personality or whether it's a
british thing i
i think it may be both um british i
think tend to be relatively orderly we
haven't rioted as much when things have
occurred that doesn't tend to be the
revolts
um that might be a uh chronic situation
it might just be an acute one for
roundabout now with the way that the
culture is at the moment
but for the most part we tend to stick
to the rules and i've
tended to respect rule makers and such
like sure but dude
the number of times since our
conversation only at the beginning of
this year
where i see something i'm like okay the
mask slipped again there yeah yeah masks
slipped again there
and it really is a red pill because once
you've seen it
you can no longer unsee it and you start
to see it more and more and more because
the pattern recognition
begins to kick in right that reticular
activating system is so highly attuned
that you start to think well i'm a
little bit skeptical about that and i'm
a little bit skeptical about that and
then you have something as blatant as
this covid's
facebook turn around and you go well
this is this is just a big billboard
saying we don't know what the [ __ ] we're
doing and we make arbitrary rules
and you get punished when they're wrong
even if you were right
before we knew and we can admit that we
were wrong
but you don't get any sort of recompense
or apology
and at a certain point you you asked
yourself wait a minute why
am how was i ever under the belief that
jeremy corbyn serkir nicholas sturgeon
boris johnson care about me
or have my best interest at heart when
they've never even met me or know i
exist
and to expect powerful people to not
be self-motivated or self-driven makes
no sense
at the very least they're not going to
be in that position if they do not have
this hunger for power because it takes
so much work to get elected
especially at the highest levels so even
as a thesis
it's completely incoherent and
nonsensical now you can make the case
which is
uh i think fairly easy to defend that
their careers will be best served
when the country itself thrives right
it's easy to get reelected when the
economy is booming
it's much harder when things are a
disaster so you they would want to seek
out those policies that
for the country and i do think all those
people do want in general probably
what's best for
and they just have different views of
getting there but to say that they're
entirely
just motivated by service when you see
how they talk
you know is is just bizarre to me
did you see the recent local election
outcomes in the uk yes i did oh very
much
what did you take away from that oh i i
was uh uh giddy um i was giddy because
i enjoy seeing anytime
politicians squirm because they're very
good at hand waving away finding excuses
and so on and so forth
so to have so labor went from corbin who
was regarded as you know the left of the
party understandably
we have new leadership we're moderating
we're changing our face
and to have you know it's kind of like
we're talking earlier about having coke
or pepsi it's like okay
my teeth are rotten i'm gonna stop
drinking coke well i'll just start
drinking pepsi that's the other choice
so labor has this you know somewhat
center left with cirque here or the
harder left that's corbin they're like
okay
this didn't it's also funnier because it
went miliband corbin
circare right so it's like okay the
moderate didn't work
let's try the alternative and that's
that's very reasonable a b testing
okay this was a complete disaster we've
had our lowest level since like the
great depression
we're going to go back to the center
nope it's still going down it's like
there's only two there's only two
buttons like what am i supposed to do
is glorious and i do
think it is also um wonderful
to demonstrate the insincerity of
politicians and labor is the perfect
example of this not that i think
boris johnson is a good person let me
just make that clear but labor just
codifies this principle i'm about to
to demonstrate they're called they're
called labor the party is called labor
it's not called the democrats here
it's specifically the party of labor it
came out the fabian society
the unions and so on and so forth as
soon as those
labor unions working men started voting
tori
to any extent they're being vilified as
little britners
backwards illiterate racist so on and so
forth it's like
wait so you never cared about labor at
all you never claimed to rep
you you did not really represent the
views of your countrymen or else you
would have been
changing your policies accordingly you
just used them or saw them
as a means to gain power and now that
they're a threat to your maintaining
power
you condemn and despise them and there
are many members of the labor
uh party who publicly were like look i
forgot the guy's name i apologize i'm
sure people know who i'm talking about
in the uk
who are like we've become this party of
like university
uh jerks who have disdain for the common
man
this is not who we're supposed to be
about nor is it a path toward winning
elections
and he i think he's absolutely spot on
and right but what's
hilarious to me is they have no idea of
what to do next
and you see this in country after
country in germany
uh the social democrats which are the
equivalent of the labor party
who have been in coalition with angela
merkel for better part over a decade
they're now polling at like 13 13
that's i mean just imagine if being in a
country
where one of the two main parties is now
down to 13
so in country after country historically
these
big parties which have had decades of
you know often running the state
or you know certainly having being
number two are imploding
and that to me as someone who has
disdain for democracy is something
absolutely wonderful
the situation it's also funny that like
in just the
story one thing british politics you
have labor which is a complete disaster
and then you have boris johnson in the
other hand he's not exactly a great guy
he's not a slick operator no right yeah
yeah is this the guy that's defeated
us this one like bongo bongo land this
is gonna be our pm it's like but that's
where we are so it's it's it's
and the thing i love as an american
there's such a
uh uh pretension to to brits looking
down on us and oh my god
it's like you guys have a lot of low
lifes at the very top and
one more thing that just happened
recently i i was having i forgot what it
was i had this tweet and i mean it
i said no matter how bad of a day you're
having right now
realize that somewhere theresa may is
miserable and
when you put it
yeah um i don't know man it watching
that situation
unfold was crazy especially from
being from the northeast of the uk which
was this labor stronghold
yeah partly pool yeah is where i used to
play cricket for years
and yeah
[Laughter]
what was it the the christmas story
quicker for yours
the arch what was it that i was talking
about the chief constable
of hampshire police or something and you
took a liking to him
um but you're totally right when you say
that it just seemed like
okay what can we do now what do you want
us to say now this was labor's campaign
so what should we say now what would you
like us to tell you
in order for us to stop depreciating
everywhere that we thought that we were
safe
so this is the thing that i found that
was really interesting man so
if it hadn't been for the fact that
trump had lost
in november or trump didn't win
the election in november people get mad
when i say that he lost you
know he didn't lose so if you
accidentally say that george floyd was
killed he was like no he wasn't he was
he died
you're like oh [ __ ] come on mate it's
just term a phrase
anyway um the fact that trump is no
longer the president right
if that hadn't happened i think that you
would have
a fairly robust case to be made that
look all of this super lefty woke-ism
stuff
it's just not resonating with the
electorate across the board
you know two of the cultural leaders
when it comes to the west
english-speaking countries it's just not
happening
but the democrat win seems to throw
a bit of a fly in the ointment of that
hypothesis
no you're seeing it wrong from across
the pond so i don't i don't think you're
following american politics during the
primaries
but bernie sanders who is kind of the
jeremy corbyn equivalent roughly
although he's much more amiable and more
much more liked and
respected person than corbin was much
less divisive
he was we have something called super
tuesday so basically we have 50 states
and each state has their primary caucus
and they're not all in the same day it's
a staggered period so basically
you kind of have the playoffs as you you
know people fall away
and then you get the nominee for each
party and we have super something called
super tuesday
which is a day when a huge chunk of
states all have their primary caucus on
the same day
the day before bernie who only joined
the democrat he's always been
independent he'll enjoy the democratic
party seeking
the presidential nomination i did four
years earlier he was ahead in the polls
in literally every state
other than i think minnesota where
senator klobuchar amy klobuchar had been
running as well
which was her home state so he had a
lock on the nomination
you know they were going to have a
social um democratic socialist as their
nominee
the democratic party publicly called
all the other nominees they said you're
ending your campaign today and endorsing
biden binds our guy
and they did it klobuchar pete buddha
judge mayor who was doing well
and they had been doing better than
biden in uh polling and delegates
that month super tuesday's tuesday
monday they all suspended their
campaigns campbell harris who had
suspended
previously endorsed biden and that put
biden over the top
so it was a defeat by the democrats
of the wokest uh who would be the equi
the champion of the wokest left it would
be the
hard left had been defeated very
heavy-handedly
and publicly by the party leadership so
the left the center left or ostensible
center left
is much more effective in many ways at
defeating the harder left
than the right or the center right is at
least here in the states
that said that didn't really happen um
in britain because it was just
biden won and you had those off your
elections and i think labor is
polling even lower now than corbyn's
historic uh defeat
yeah it's crazy and it's also
counter-intuitive the data because not
that long earlier when theresa may
called her snap election
corbyn did better than miliband had done
previously so if you're looking at the
data
you can't say you know the corbin
approach is a disaster because there was
one
election where he gave her a run for her
money
she blew up like a 20-point lead or
something crazy yeah then there's
another election where it's their worst
result in like 90 years
and then you go okay we're going to go
to cirque here now it's going it's like
i i
if i were labor there's a lot of
conflicting data here and i don't blame
them for being confused
um yeah but do you see my point to do
with america that
i understand you can have top-down
people
litigating or telling the candidates
that they need to move in one direction
or another but bottom-up the electorate
again questions about the validity of
the election aside
the electorate seemed to not
have this total whitewash correct
correct conservative wash as you say
what do you think's
different there what was the what was
the key differences why are we seeing
such a conservative push in the uk and
not in the us
uh i think we are i i don't know that's
a that's i don't know that i'm familiar
enough to with the differences to be
able to make uh i'm sure a lot of us do
with personalities
by insert here aren't the same
phenomenon boris johnson maybe
and trump are more similar than the two
of those other two
uh and it would have to do with
different populations i do
think from what i understand and please
correct me if i'm wrong you guys had
brexit obviously we didn't have a big
issue like that
so to have a uh you would think
that in that red wall where so many
people were for brexit even though they
were
reliable labor voters for labor to then
be like okay
we're this is what you got like theresa
may was a remainer
and she was like okay i'm still pushing
through brexit when she was
on the steps of number 10 her first day
she said brexit means brexit
i'm going to you know get this through
and that she wasn't really able to do
that but she wasn't like i'm gonna undo
this election i'm gonna
but with labor it's my understanding uh
this is something was a very populist
thing the entire establishment largely
or almost the entiretory establishment
all the
largely the labor people even though
corbin apparently quietly was a remainer
um they didn't really know what to do as
opposed to this would be a good example
for them to pivot
and maybe be like okay uh um we're gonna
we're thank you forget it's it's like
out in what 1945
when winston churchill stood there on
the balcony and he said he told the
people this is your victory and they
yelled at him no this is yours
so it would be smart i would think maybe
i'm sure the labor people are smarter
than i am
in terms of what it's like uk politics
to say like all right
thank you boris for delivering us brexit
we'll take it from here you tori tory
leadership has been a disaster
you're great at alienating us from
europe
but we're going to make sure that europe
has a good relationship with the united
kingdom
which it always has had in our labor you
know you can the speech is kind of right
themselves
um but i think they for whatever reason
chose not to do this
and i think a lot of it because so much
of the left increasingly
are uh you know at the mercy of
corporate media
which is much harder left especially in
the states
than the politicians themselves are it's
an interesting point i do think that
brexit makes a huge
huge contribution to this because it was
such a landmark
uh point for for everybody in the
country and you didn't have
that single issue
in yeah the most recent american
election
right right he just didn't have that one
thing
that could be grasped onto whereas i
think
when trump got first elected there
perhaps was a little bit it was as
simpler
a simpler campaign to look at right you
have this
woman is a crook she's going to do
terrible things to this country
build a wall there we go it was a fairly
sort of simple
campaign to wrap your head around but
this one i don't think was
so much it was more multivariate and
also 2010 is a better example because
obama was
elected in 2008 he had super majorities
in both houses of
congress they start pushing through
obamacare which at the time was
enormously unpopular
uh the polls were violently against it
the democratic party still pushed it
through
and then you had the midterm elections
and they were a bloodbath now
they were starting from a huge level so
they weren't completely destroyed
but it was really when you have these
one-issue elections
or that shadow is floating over the the
electorate
uh that's something that it's very easy
uh for the other party to leverage or at
least for the party in power
are gonna even if the other party can't
leverage it they're still going to lose
a lot of their clout
why do you think that the left have so
much contempt for the working class
because it's a lot easier to train a
smart dog
than a dumb dog and i don't i in general
so educated college university people
are much more
easily uh manipulated by the media much
more subservient by the media because
they've been spent all these years
training
whereas people who are intelligent but
uneducated like the working class
are much more skeptical uh if you know
if you're if you're in a
a factory and your boss is telling you
how you're all a big family
blah blah blah you're like sure thing
boss and you go you go to your boys and
you roll your eyes because you know he's
telling you what he wants to hear
but if you're in management you might
start to believe it
so i think this kind of two paths to
perception
is a big part of it um
i don't think the working man correctly
believes that the media uh regards them
with respect to put it mildly
well the media definitely not right and
if you have the media
and labor saying largely the same things
and this population thinks you're a jerk
and a horrible person
well you're agreeing with everything
else i would bet that you're saying
these things behind closed doors and
they're probably right
that's a really interesting insight that
the vehicle
which used to be prized or still perhaps
is prized as the delivery mechanism for
a lot of the talking points from
politicians
the normal working-class view
their interpretation of that industry
at large is perhaps becoming so jaded
that even the association with it is
now tarnishing any potential messages
which it was
this is like being judge durian
executioner of yourself you're kind of
hamstrung
by your own situation yeah and it also
it's simple just about uh putting food
on the table this is what happened in
1978
when thatcher was head of the tories and
she hired sachin sachi and they had a
brilliant ad campaign with all the the
welfare cues and the slogan simply was
labor isn't working
i mean just a brilliant turn of phrase
and at a certain point
you know democracy this is the best
thing you could say about democracy
there's this
articulator like okay if there are these
two choices and this
one isn't working and i have two
alternatives it's not a hard choice i'm
at the very least gonna at least try
this other one
no matter what you tell me about this
woman because as things stand now
this is not working for me now it's very
easy to make the argument that she was
very bad for the working class you know
the minors so on and so forth and many
that's a big argument to be had
but in terms of uh you know feeling this
connection
as a working man and the powers that be
i mean the tories exploited this very
well in 78 and
obviously that led to her election in
79. what do you think of the
relationship
between the left and the working class
in america
oh it's it's being gloriously bifurcated
and there is
a uh increasing i i don't think people
in britain
understand and i as someone who's
in knee deep in this world have trouble
understanding
how radicalized and how quickly the
working class is in the states
and i had this tweet and i said this on
rogan that
if they started putting up guillotines
corporate journalists will be tripping
over themselves to make fun of how dull
the blades are
i think there is something meaning like
they don't realize that they're playing
with fire that these
people are really being very radicalized
uh in very uh um dangerous ways
that they feel correctly that
uh you know the corporate media is their
enemy now when you regard someone as
your enemy my result is
i don't want to talk to them i don't
want to deal with them but it's very
dangerous
when a lot of people identify another
group as the enemy and
someone's going to get ideas and that is
something i'm very very concerned about
something i'm warning against but
they're sitting in their offices well
now in their homes thanks to kovid and
are like hahaha look at these idiots you
know putting up these uh um
uh gallows it's like you guys this if
you
talk and the left knows this
historically when you have when you
marginalize a person or a group
and they have nothing to lose and you
keep poking them what do you think is
going to happen
it's going to end up in it's going to
blow up in ways no one wants and i'm
very very concerned about this
what do you think happens roll the clock
forward i i don't even want to speculate
because this is the kind of thing where
it's like tinder boxes you know like you
like that match
and uh violence sings its own song and i
i am desperately hoping we did not reach
that point
man well we will wait and see dude so
good to have you here
we are not doing well it doesn't look
like we're going to get to do russia
russia russia russia
yeah yes you're going to have to we're
going to have to yeah
what are we going to do we need to do
something else we'll cross the pond baby
we gotta i can't get in i literally
can't get into your country the whole
shenzhen
shenzhen zone is shut off you're like a
walled [ __ ] nation at the moment uh
one of us is gonna cross that atlantic
one way or another or we're gonna have
to meet sweetheart or something
swim yeah well dude ma'am we need to do
some things we had this russia thing
planned to go and it'll be three years
in a row yeah
yes and um we're not going to get to
well maybe i guess but something fairly
sort of dramatic would have to change i
guess but we need to do something man so
we will um we'll get some plans made i i
am could not be more looking forward to
this content that creates as a result
because this is going to be the buddy
comedy
movie in real life right don't you think
i i think it makes an interesting
pairing yes definitely it's not as crazy
as jackie chan and chris tucker but it's
still going to be
fun for a lot of people plus wait you
laugh but let me get serious for a
second
i think uh i one of the things i despise
is cynicism
uh and this kind of it's um i'm too cool
for school attitude which is very common
in media
so i think a lot of people have had a
very lonely time
so when they see two people who are good
friends
having fun it's it's good spiritual fuel
for them
and clowning each other so yeah although
it's going to be going more
more in one direction than the other but
that's fine fantastic right well we're
going to have to pay back somewhere
aren't we so man thank you so much um
the
anarchist handbook will be linked in the
show notes below michael mallis on
twitter and all of that other good
stuff it's just anarchisthandbook.com
that's all they need to know
that's a really cool thing to finish up
with that's a really smart idea that i
haven't seen
other people use before most other
authors when they need to direct people
to where to get the book it's search it
on amazon
or use one of those amz dot to slash
as opposed to what z oh right yeah sorry
why is that it's not a person's name
that makes no sense
x y zed is that comment below if i've
got z
wrong as a british person i don't know
you got it right but it makes no sense
that
that letter would have a name well i
mean if this isn't let me just remind
you this isn't your language anyway
actually we speak closer to british
english than you guys do
what is a russian no it's a russian as
an american you guys are the degenerate
where were you born
russia right okay so this
i i can't believe that i can't believe
that arushan
is trying to tell me about how to speak
my language
no well the chief constable of west ham
we'll be making a call to you sir is he
gonna tell me that's not cricket
that he will be saying that's not
cricket i don't just love it
okay uh anarchisthandbook.com
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace
you